sujet la santé encore avec une première
en france en matière de procréation
assistée la naissance d'un bébé par
maturation in vitro c'est le nom de
cette technique elle s'adresse aux
femmes victimes de troubles hormonaux et
pour lesquels la fécondation in vitro
est particulièrement pénible
nathalie s'appelle un frédéric basket
c'était il ya 21 ans
la naissance d'amandine premier bébé
éprouvette aujourd'hui c'est heavy né la
semaine dernière mais que nous ne
verrons pas qui fait la fierté du père
d'amandine une petite fille de 3 kg
premier bébé conçu selon une technique
novatrice la maturation in vitro sa
vraie scène catégorie de patientes
particulière qui ont tendance à
fabriquer beaucoup de vue elle la
fabrique trop ce qui pose un problème
parce que l on fabrique tôt donc elles
n'arrivent pas bien ovules et pour ces
femmes
la fiv classique représente un risque
les piqûres d'hormones qui pendant deux
semaines accélère l'ovulation et peuvent
provoquer des tistes avec la maturation
in vitro
cette étape et court-circuité l'ovocyte
est prélevée au début du cycle et mûri
dans une éprouvette pendant 48 heures
plus de piqûres plus d'hormones et plus
d'effets secondaires
les femmes peuvent souffrir d'une prise
de poids parfois importantes d'une perte
des cheveux réversible de douleurs
abdominales de nausées de vomissements
cette technique est déjà pratiqué dans
plusieurs pays notamment en australie et
au canada
les premières naissances ont eu lieu en
1998 il a eu 200 enfants qui sont nés
actuellement il ya eu aucune pathologie
observées chez ces enfants
pour l'instant la maturation in vitro ne
concerne que 5 % des femmes stériles
mais ces progrès représente un grand
espoir pour toutes les zones